[Music]
[Applause]
what's going on happy holidays in
today's lesson with Harry Potter and the
Goblet of Fire you are going to learn
with a scene in which Ron Harry and
Hermione attend a Christmas ball that is
a large formal party in which people
dance and that in the movies is known as
the Yule Ball now Yul is an old word for
Christmas which is used still in
northern Europe and North America in
some specific context around the
holidays so this is a really great
opportunity for you to learn all about
British culture and some differences
between British and American
pronunciation and if you're new here
every single week we make fun lessons
like this one so that you can understand
fast speaking natives without getting
lost without missing the jokes and
without subtitles just like this learner
who says that they are amazed at how
fast that their comprehension has
improved by watching our lessons over
the last year and you're going to learn
super fast too all you have to do is hit
that subscribe button and the bell down
below so you don't miss any of our new
lessons
[Music]
hello
all those like those my dress robes but
then I will ride no lace oh don't you
ill color well I spent you look for this
traditional for their ancient I don't
know Mike Reitan kissing smell on my
gray on Jesse murder me Harry
poor kid but she's alone a number of
them cry your eyes out who mining of
course come on happy don't you think she
wouldn't tell us no she's coming with me
because we take the mickey out of her
she did nobody asked her or taken him
myself she went some bloody proud
hello boys don't you look dashing oh
yeah you are Porter a humorous potato
ready ready professor did in its its
traditional that the three champions
will in this case four are the first to
dance Sharia don't you vote no oh yeah
well no you know what Oh
as for you mr. Issa you may you may
proceed into the Great Hall with Miss
potato oh there you are
[Music]
hello in British English badges have
bloody when used as slang like down here
as intensity and emotion to a sentence
emphasizing what you are saying in a
slightly rude way Harry you'll go with
Malfoy okay then I get fine fine just so
you know he's a bloody coward
[Music]
so a common collocation with the word
bloody is the slang expression of bloody
hell said to express anger frustration
or surprise wake up wake up honestly get
dressed and don't go that suit
all those those my dress rugs a robe is
a long lose piece of clothing normally
worn on very formal occasions such as
when graduating from college or when
judges are working in court in the
Wizarding World
it's common for wizards and witches to
wear robes as all Hogwarts students do a
dress robe is an old term used to refer
to a type of robe worn for parties and
social events similar to the kind of
clothes weren't for gala events nowadays
so Ron says Harry's dress robes are
alright her thumbs my dress robes but
they have awry when used to refer to the
level of quality of something
all right means acceptable good enough
Ron is frustrated because his mother
sent him very old out of fashion dress
robes to wear for the Yule Ball
lowlights
don't you co-op lace is a decorative
cloth made of delicate patterns with
holes in them collar is the part around
the neck of a piece of clothing if you
describe someone or something as dodgy
you disapprove of them because they seem
rather dishonest and unreliable example
the driver of those mountains can be
quite dodgy Ron meant he thinks the
collars of bad quality or simply too
old-fashioned
this is not a common application for
this expression well I should pay
traditional traditional can describe
anything that Polish tradition or a
usual way of doing things for a long
time
for example traditional Mexican food
includes tortillas and beans a bag of
porn chips and chili and fake cheese
sauce on the other hand is not
traditional so here Harry tries to make
Ron feel better by saying he thinks his
robes are more traditional meaning they
fall in order and more classic style
than Harry's robes well I spent using
traditional for the right Inchon ancient
means very old in a sense of being older
than old for example ancient history
normally refers to the time before the
Middle Ages
my dad has three tattoos like why your
dad you know it's so sad when parents
try the mom double pierced one of her
ears and I'm like hello you're 50 so
ancient have an amusing I don't know my
crayon kissing smell of my crayon Jessie
you probably know a person's aunt is a
sister of their mother or father so a
great aunt is a sister of their
grandmother or grandfather madam a hairy
murder me or kill me is a favorite of
expression said when you're so sad or
discouraged by something you have to do
that you would rather die than do it
this is a figure of speech
not meant to be taken literally enjoy
your stay at Caesars we hope it's toga
rific kill me kill me now the expression
leave it alone means to not interact or
interfere with something Harry is asking
Ron to stop being worried about his
clothes we can also call it gate this
expression with people for example leave
me alone or leave her alone meaning a
request to stop bothering somebody
famous Harry Potter can't even go to a
bookshop without making the front page
alright Potter you got yourself a
girlfriend no JK nicely
a whole kid but she's a learning number
I'm crying her eyes out oh my gosh here
we can hear a word that is commonly
mispronounced by learners the function
word of many learners will actually make
the mistake of pronouncing the sound of
the letter F as you should do in the
word off in reality what should be said
in of is the sound of the letter V of
off of course now one of the many
differences in pronunciation between
American and British English accents as
you probably know is the R sound when
referring to how the R sound is
pronounced axis of English are divided
into those that are Rohtak meaning they
pronounce R in all circumstances and
those that are non-rhotic which only
pronounce it before a vowel so they
don't pronounce it before a consonant or
at the end of a word non-rhotic accent
can still pronounce it at the end of a
word if the word is immediately followed
by another word beginning with a vowel
so car may be pronounced kha but car and
bus is pronounced car and bus similar to
how Americans would normally say it
let's check out some other examples of
words with the R sound sent in both
standard American and British accents
we're doing the right thing right of
course we are well the guys worked here
for 25 years yes but I've lived here for
25 minutes
[Music]
hey do you want to improve your American
English pronunciation and comprehension
well then I highly recommend our fluent
with friends course where every week for
48 weeks you will receive a fun lesson
that follows along with the first two
seasons of the TV series friends plus
you get 20 plus page PDF power lessons
vocabulary memorization software access
to our floozie sort of global community
and so much more
plus you can try for free right now with
our three-part master class what are you
waiting for
just look up here or down on the
scription below and you can sign up for
that and right now okay I should learn
another eyes out here you can see a more
informal use of the adjective poor which
normally describes a person who has
little money and few possessions in the
scene rhonda leaves her money is not
going to the ball because she had no
partner to go with so calling hermione a
poor kid means he feels sympathy for her
he's expressing his sadness about the
fact she's not going to the ball the
expression i bet means the same as i
believe or I expect but she learning
never crying her eyes out what would be
another informal way to say I bet in
this sentence
[Music]
now literally in another context to bet
is to risk money or an object on the
result of an event or competition in the
hope of winning more money if somebody
is crying their eyes out they are crying
a lot Oh kid I should learn a number of
them cry your eyes out who my new of
course come on don't you think she
wouldn't tell us where she's coming with
because we take the mickey out of her
she did to take the mickey out of
somebody is an old and very uncommon
British English expression meaning to
mock somebody to laugh and make fun of
somebody especially in an unkind way I'm
buddy Austin
or taking it myself she want somebody
proud the adjective proud describes
somebody who feels pride it has a few
different applications with positive and
negative connotations if you say you are
proud of somebody else you feel good
about being responsible for supporting
somebody else when they are successful
my perfect sister being who she was it
can also mean you have or show respect
for yourself recognizing that you are
responsible for your own achievement now
a French North please treat the proud
sounds of drum sprang and the high
master Eagle tasarov
in the case of what Ron said he put it
as a negative idea meaning that she was
being arrogant and overly respectful of
herself he's referring to a previous
conversation they had in the movie it's
one thing for blog to show up alone
forget it's just so I wouldn't be going
alone because believe it or not
someone's asked me
[Music]
and I said yes
she's not alone if you say so
hello boys don't you look
dashing here Padma used an informal
expression to make an observation about
Ron's looks when we say for example
don't you look nice
we are simply making a comment
expressing a positive surprise and how
the other person does look nice if a man
is said to look dashing
that means he looks stylish and
attractive and an adventurous and
exciting way obviously
Padma said this in sincerely in order to
be polite as Ron is definitely not
looking good and in style are you and
mr. Patel ready there you are as an
expression used most commonly as a
greeting with somebody you were just
waiting or looking for
[Music]
[Applause]
are you
it's rockin an ogre just Oh
can you
[Applause]
what isn't it it's going to go and get
drinks she can't see us did not care to
join you and Victor
what we want in a knot is a damn strap
your fan hisin with the enemy the enemy
it wasn't wanting his autograph
besides the whole point of the
tournament is International magical
cooperation to make friends I think he's
got a bit more than friendship on his
mind
[Music]
it's using you how dare you besides I
can take care of myself
dally he's way too old what that's what
you think that's what I think no the
solution then don't you know on text I'm
miserable up the courage nice me
before somebody else does and not as a
last resort well sorry it's just
completely off the point hurry
have you been never mind off to bed both
of you they are scary when they get
older fine you spoiled everything
[Music]
doesn't it
victims can get drinks she has joined us
would you care to do something is a
formal expression used to ask someone
politely whether they want to do
something so would you care to join me
on our first dance as husband and wife
we don't care to join you and victim
who knows what's got your one in a knot
is an idiomatic expression from the
Wizarding World which expresses a
person's curiosity as to why the other
is in a bad mood this is not an actual
expression that is used in the real
world but it may be a creative
alternative to real expressions like
what's got your panties or knickers in a
bunch example don't get your knickers in
a bunch I will help you in just a few
minutes
what other real expression could we use
in this case
[Music]
both alternatives B and C are correct
and are said by natives to express the
same idea hey are you a muggle who loves
the Wizarding World well then I highly
recommend you check out this playlist
where you can learn with all the movies
and the characters from Harry Potter and
greatly improve your English like magic
check that out up here or down
description below after you finish this
lesson it's a TV show you'll find high
zoom with the enemy to fraternize with
somebody is to become friends with
somebody especially if that person is
from an opposing side or team or has a
different social position for example in
this scene from friends that happens at
Ross's workplace the Museum of Natural
History we say that the scientists don't
fraternize with the tour guys only the
people in the white coats sit over there
and only the people in the blue blazes
sit over here that's just the way it is
that's crazy
raus raus over here man I said you see
okay I'm cool over here I'll catch up
with you later job in the scene Ron
refers to Viktor Krum as the enemy if
you've watched Harry Potter and the
Goblet of Fire
you should know Crum is a student from
another school who is also competing in
the Triwizard Tournament the enemy it
wasn't one scene he's also crap so here
Hermione makes a sarcastic comment
asking Ron who wasn't wanting his
autograph as early in the movie Ron was
actually a fan of Crum who is a famous
professional Quidditch player besides
the whole point of the tournament is
International magical cooperation to
make friends if somebody explains and
talks about the whole points of
something they are emphasizing the
purpose for doing something especially
when they believe such purpose is not
being understood or has been forgotten
by other people example I don't like the
lego video games I think the whole point
of a toy like Lego is using your hands
to build things not a mouse in a
computer screen thing he's got a bit
more than friendship on his mind
Ron means Victor has second intentions
in his relationship with Hermione that
he wants to be more than friends with
her and perhaps become her boyfriend
using you
how dare you is an informal expression
said when you are very shocked or angry
about something that someone has said or
done so Hermione is angry with Ron
because he's insulting Crum and Hermione
by saying that he is using her meaning
that he is taking advantage of her it's
using you besides I can take care of
myself
dalek he's way too old what when
somebody says I doubt it
they are disagreeing with the other
person they have different opinions so
Ron says Viktor is way too old in this
phrase way as extra emphasis - too old
it makes them meaning stronger
this will just be my badge that's what
you think that's what I think no the
solution then don't you know on text I'm
miserable
pack up the courage knots me before
somebody else does and not as a last
resort to pluck up your courage is an
idiomatic phrase meaning to force
yourself to be brave enough to do
something although you are frightened or
worried about it the term last resort
refers to the only choice that remains
for somebody after all other
alternatives or solutions have been
tried run the tests you can do a brain
biopsy but only as a last resort well
it's just completely off the point if we
refer to an argument or comment as off
the point that means it is not important
or not related to the purpose of the
discussion all right
have you been never mind off the bed
both of you never mind is an expression
used for telling someone that they don't
need to do something or worry about it
anymore because it is not important or
because you will do it yourself what do
I just so let's go if you are off to bed
you're going to go to sleep it can also
be used as a command as Hermione did
here have you been
never mind off the bed both of you like
it's scary when they come over fine a
spoiled everything
in this sense to spoil something is to
destroy or damage something especially
we're making it not able to be used
anymore for example spoiled eggs would
be eggs that are run and inedible
hermione is referring to how Ron spoiled
the moment as she is nothing sad and
unable to enjoy the party you spoiled
everything
so after hearing this exchange between
Ron and Hermoine
Harry gets confused ask Ron what's this
about that is another way of asking what
is the reason for this or what's up with
this
[Music]
how
all those photos my dress robes but then
I will ride low lace oh don't you ill
color well I spent yours look for this
traditional from their ancient I don't
know Mike Reitan kissing smell on my
gray on Jesse murder me Harry
poor kid but she's a learning over him
cry your eyes out
who - course come on happy why do you
think she wouldn't tell us know she was
coming with because we take the mickey
out of her if she did
you
nobody asked her or taken him myself she
wants a bloody proud hello boys don't
you look
dashing
you
oh yeah you are Porter a humorous Patel
ready ready professor
did and its its traditional that the
three champions well in this case four
are the first to dance
Julia don't you act no oh yeah well now
you know
Oh as for you mr. Issa you may you may
proceed into the Great Hall with Miss
potato oh there you are
[Applause]
doesn't it thumps go and get drinks
she can't join us did not care to join
you and Victor
we weren't in a knot there's a damn
strap you're fraternizing with the enemy
the enemy who wasn't wanting his
autograph besides the whole point of the
tournament is International magical
cooperation to make friends I think he's
got a bit more than friendship on his
mind
choosing you how dare you besides I can
take care of myself
dally he's way too old what that's what
you think that's what I think you know
the solution then don't you throw on
text I'm miserable
pack up the courage nice me before
somebody else does and not some last
resort
well sorry it's just completely off the
point
you
hurry have you been
never mind off to bed both of you
they get scary when they kill all the
fun you spoiled everything
[Music]
all right I hope the Yule Ball helped to
get you in the Christmas spirit and I
hope that you'll go and watch the full
Goblet of Fire movie then if you want to
take your English to the next level and
check out one of our other dynamite
lessons here and now it's time to go
beyond the classroom and live your
English aha yeah